Okay. This is very serious. Donald Trump is
just making stuff up about the raid that led
to the death by suicide have ISIS leader,
Abu Bakar al-Baghdadi. Donald Trump has told
a whole bunch of different lies about it.
Specific ones generalize, like lie by implication
where Donald Trump was golfing at the time
of the raid, but later staged a picture in
the situation room about 95 minutes later
to make it seem as though he was there squinting
in the way that I've really only have seen
Donald Trump do, which I think he may, he
thinks makes him look strong. Uh, there've
been all sorts of different lies and deceptions,
but Donald Trump also, uh, uh, aside from
barely being able to pronounce Abu Bach or
all Baghdadi's name during that post raid,
uh, speech that he gave, he said some things
that are leaving Trump administration officials
wondering, where the hell did Donald Trump
get that? Let's take a look at the video.
Last night, the United States brought the
world's number one terrorist leader to justice,
IBU by car. al-Baghdadi is dead. No personnel
were lost in the operation. While a large
number of Baghdadi's fighters and companions
were killed with him, he died after running
into a dead end tunnel, whimpering and crying
and screaming all the way. The compound had
been cleared by this time with people either
surrendering or being shot and killed. 11
young children were moved out of the house
and are uninjured. The only ones remaining
were Baghdadi in the tunnel and he had dragged
three of his young children with him. They
were led to certain death. He reached the
end of the tunnel as our dogs chased him down.
He ignited his vest killing himself and the
three children, his body was mutilated by
the blast. The tunnel had caved in on it in
addition, but test results gave certain immediate
and totally positive identification. It was
him.
There's a lot there, uh, that Trump administration
officials have no idea where Trump got it.
Donald Trump says that AGU bok are all Baghdadi
died, whimpering, crying, and screaming. Donald
Trump was not given audio of the incident.
We now know that Donald Trump had overhead
surveillance footage without audio. How does
he know that Al Baghdadi was whimpering, crying
and screaming despite the fact that Trump
had no audio and it allegedly took place in
a tunnel and Trump had overhead video? Well
the answer is he doesn't know that it's a
lie. It is just a straight up bold faced lie.
And immediately when Donald Trump said this,
staffers started messaging each other asking,
where did Donald Trump get this about whimpering,
crying and screaming. Nobody knew. So then
Donald Trump was asked about it and he just
insisted he's telling the truth. But these
are lies. Donald Trump's saying he doesn't
want to talk about it, but then repeats the
exact same lies.
Oh, your video hook up with a web ring of
a bad day. I don't want to talk about it.
But, uh, he was screaming, crying, and whimpering.
Uh, and he was scared out of his mind. And
think of James Foley, think of Kayla, think
of the things he did to Kayla, what he did
to fall in so many others. And for those people
that say, Oh, isn't this a little violent?
Think of how many times have you seen men,
I think in all cases, men for the most. But
in terms of this, will you see the orange
suits?
You don't want to talk about it, but then
you repeat the same lies. Uh, then Donald
Trump goes off into other tangents after repeating
the same lie to sort of try to change the
subject. This is a reality of Donald Trump's
own construction that exists only in the mind
of Donald Trump. Reporters went to the Pentagon
to try to confirm some of this. The Pentagon
said, we don't have those details and they
shut their mouths. The next day. The chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff said, I don't
have that information. Maybe Donald Trump
has other information. Check it out.
President Trump described yesterday, Baghdadi
wimpery and crying before he died. Can you
elaborate or confirm those details? I secretary
was that same question yesterday. Um, I know
the president had planned to talk down to
the unit and, and unit members. Uh, but I,
I don't know what the source of that was there,
but I assume it was talking directly to unit
unit members.
Yup. I have no idea where Donald Trump got
that. But I don't know. I guess he must have
talked to someone. So it's really important
that we on the left, take a rational, balanced
approach on this issue. ISIS is horrible.
They are terrorists losing their leader hurts
ISIS to some degree. That's good. This was
not a good person. The world is better off
with this person not alive and to some degree,
even if temporarily, it damages ISIS. Now
that being said, Donald Trump is number one
overstating his role in this entire thing.
Number two was golfing at the time, but later
stage the picture of himself in the situation.
That is a form of lying. Number three, Trump
is overstating the importance of killing one
leader when you really aren't doing anything
to root out the ideology that inspires the
terrorist, and in fact, you may further inspire
more people to become radicalized merely by
killing someone putatively or ostensibly known
as the leader of the organization.
And number four, we learned that he's also
lying about details like claiming that Abu
Bocker, all Baghdadi was whimpering, crying
and screaming, something that Donald Trump
couldn't have possibly known and that no one
is willing to corroborate. This is not how
we should be operating. Even mixed in with
the accomplishments that are implicit in taking
out the leader of such a terrible terrorist
organization. The way that this is being handled
is riddled with embarrassment the world over.
Even Trump's own staffers are saying, yeah,
we don't know where he's coming up with this
stuff. It is yet another one of these horrible
toxic embarrassments. And there was a very
interesting video done yesterday that compared
and contrasted the way Barack Obama handled
the killing of Osama bin Laden compared with
how Donald Trump has handled the death by
suicide of Abu Bach are all Baghdadi. And
it's not about you. You know, every, every
president does things and particularly in
foreign policy that progressives would be
against.
That's no different with Barack Obama, the
drone policy. We've got a long list of stuff.
But after being desensitized to Trump for
almost three years now, to go back and see
how a normal person handled the killing of
a terrorist and to compare it to Trump, it's
stunning, stunning how far we've fallen. And,
uh, it's, I I to call it anything other than,
than depressing, uh, seems to be sort of missing
the, the promotes prominent feeling that I'm
experiencing when I see this, the, this stuff.